[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur salis welt
heute gibt es ein wunsch rezept von
sarah und dreimal dürft ihr raten es
gibt käsekuchen er einen lotus
käsekuchen vielleicht kennt ihr alle
diese lotis kekse das sind eigentlich
einfach nur spekulation und die gibt es
einfach das ganze jahr über frei
verkäuflich nicht nur zur weihnachtszeit
und die sind schon extrem lecker man
kennt sie vielleicht aus kaffee ist da
gibt es immer so einen lotus bis kopf
keks so zum kaffee dazu und das ist
schon sehr gut und daraus wird jetzt der
käsekuchen gemacht da bekommt nämlich
einen lotus boden dafür brauche ich auch
nur 100 gramm butter die habe ich
bereits verflüssigt in der mikrowelle
wir können auch den herd verwenden und
250 gramm lotus kekse das war es schon
und eigentlich ist es auch kein
hexenwerk der ofen ist auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 160 grad ober unterhitze
jetzt das nächste das dampfen
denis renner und horst vinken
aliens
[Musik]
mit butter dazu
das weicht auch schön alle kekse auf
und wenn sie nicht gestorben ist sagt
kraemer cd keksen
manchen 200 jahren gibt es meine videos
macht
da gucken die so denken sich die alte
das passiert denn da gemacht
jetzt habe ich hier schon einen
tortenring auf 24 cm eingestellt und da
kommt die masse rein und wird schön
flach gedrückt und dann nehmt jetzt
entweder ein glas oder zum beispiel die
bürger presse
ich mache tatsächlich mehr kuchen mit
der bürger presse als mörder aber ich
glaube es okay
[Musik]
und dann kommt der boden jetzt schon mal
bei 160 grad in den ofen kann 15 minuten
vorgegangen werden und die zwischenzeit
nützlich und kann schon mal die käse
krieg erstellen
[Musik]
dafür nehme ich 700 gramm frischkäse 100
gramm sahne 250 km lotus creme 50 gramm
zucker und fünf eier
das ist echt kein kooperations video
haben die lotus grimm gekauft und die
kekse aber es ist einfach sehr lecker
deswegen ist jetzt alles von lotus
red hat mir neulich einfach ein tolles
gemacht abends mit lotus ich dachte ein
käse braucht einfach eine lodge in not
ist host naja wichtig ist jetzt bei der
creme dass sie nicht schaumig und luftig
geschlagen wird also alles vergessen was
ich bisher immer aussage mit lange
röhren schaurig schön das muss jetzt
cremig gerührt werden das heißt niedrige
stufe beim handrührgerät
und wirklich keine luft einschlagen
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt die lotus creme dazu
und ich habe jetzt auch den zucker date
zusätzlich dazu kommt echt reduziert
also da so ein standard käsekuchen
rezept von mir eigentlich so ein
bisschen abgewandelt vom new york
cheesecake
und staaten zu gerettet weil die creme
schon sehr süß und ich habe auch so
ähnlich mal einen erdnussbutter
schokoladen käsekuchen gemacht und das
ist auch richtig gut käsekuchen da gibt
es einfach zu viele variationen ich
glaube es gibt nicht ein ende am
käsekuchen rezepten sorgt die zutaten
auch kurz einrühren
und dann einen nach dem anderen
immer erst komplett einrühren und dann
das nächste
[Musik]
diese schön aus und die creme lasse ich
jetzt einfach kurz stehen wartet darauf
bis der boden fertig gebacken ist und
dann geht es gleich weiter
[Musik]
der boden ist gebacken und ich habe
ihnen kurz fünf minuten stehen lassen
das einfach nicht mehr so heiß ist da
kommt jetzt die füllung einfach rein
wird schön glatt gestrichen und dann mag
ich den kuchen bei 160 grad 15 minuten
weiter stellt dann die hitze runter und
backen noch mal für ungefähr 45 bis 60
minuten
[Musik]
die werden ganz schön schwer
es war nicht mehr so heißt deswegen ging
[Musik]
der lotus corinne ist gebacken ich habe
ihnen auch nach dem backen etwa 15 bis
20 minuten im ofen noch ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen also einfach offen tür
auf dann wieder so halb zu da durfte
abkühlen und dann habe ich ihn nach dem
kompletten erkalten hier in der küche in
den kühlschrank gestellt damit das schön
kalt wird jetzt kommt da weil der lotus
kuchen ja schon ein relativ cremige
auserkoren ist noch eine fruchtig drauf
die könnt ihr gerne weglassen wenn ihr
jetzt keine früchte mit aber es passt
schon ganz gut ich nehme dafür jetzt 200
gramm beeren entweder tief gefrorene
oder frische himbeeren die tiefgefroren
und einfach auftauchen lassen 100 gramm
wasser und ein halbes päckchen agha also
keine halbe tüte da könnt ihr euch auch
ein bisschen immer an der rückseite der
verpackung orientieren ag ist ein
pflanzliches geliermittel also die
wisag hat die alternative zur gelatine
und eine tüte bindet 500 milliliter
flüssigkeit und da brauche ich jetzt
einfach eine halbe tüte und jetzt
zerkleinert ihr alles in einem mixer
saisonstart mitzunehmen können egal
dann das wasser dazu
und einmal parieren
und dann kommt es hier direkt in einem
topf wird mit dem acker berührt und dann
muss es wirklich zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen da dürft ihr euch auch
gerne die uhrzeit stellen denn dann
beginnt erst das aka aka zu wirken und
bin dann eben auch die flüssigkeit
[Musik]
jetzt ist dem masse fertig ich will sie
kurzum damit sie einfach schneller
abkühlen kann denn der kupfer topf der
speichert doch schon einiges an ferme du
kannst nicht so schnell ab und ich lasse
jetzt lauwarm abgehört ihr könnt
übrigens hier auch immer eine lehrprobe
machen und schauen ob es wirklich
funktioniert hat mit eurem aka aka oder
mit der gelatine auch einfach so ein
bisschen was in kleinen teller geben
oder in schälchen kurz in den
kühlschrank stellen und dann sollte es
wirklich innerhalb von einer minute
ungefähr schon anfangen zu verlieren und
fest werden dass hier lasse ich jetzt
kurz etwa lauwarm abkühlen
aber ich hole jetzt schon mal den kuchen
aus dem kühlschrank den kann ich nämlich
gleich raus lösen und ich noch ein paar
kekse zerbröseln denn eigentlich kann
ich das dann gleich drauf gießen und den
kuchen fertig dekoriert dann ist er
fertig
sich dann erstmal hierüber mit folie und
dann könnt ihr die nämlich darunter
wegzappen
und einmal durch
dann ist es gut genug
und dann vorsichtig den rand lösen
[Musik]
irgendwo im
rohbau
so konnte ich kurz die rallye a probe
guckt mal so sieht es der probe aus also
ist schön fest geworden
fast perfekt
und dann kommt jetzt hier die hamas
herein
der schöne frucht später
[Musik]
so ein bisschen verteilen aber nicht
ganz bis zum rand damit es nicht runter
läuft
[Musik]
den stelle ich kurz in den kühlschrank
damit die masse fest wird es dauert etwa
ein bis zwei minuten das geht recht
schnell und dann kann ich hier die kekse
schon mal zerbröseln zu der deckung
[Musik]
jetzt die oberfläche schon fast fest und
ich würde sagen die kekse kommen hier so
an den rand
da kann man auch mal ganz schön schön
und rand kaschieren
[Musik]
und ich finde damit man sieht dass es
ein lob des tages nach lospech gebraucht
aber dann nehme ich die hier die
gefüllten
oder es war mehr drin die gibt es aber
auch mit los ist wenn
[Musik]
jetzt nicht die richtige creme
der schock groß
lassnig kabul ich würde dir jetzt auch
so dahin legen
so hochkommt ich glaube so hochkant rein
und wenn man dann an schnitt hat das ich
glaube ich schon ganz gut aus kann
jemand ja oder nein machen ja ne risiko
dorf ja
ich schneide dir mal an und probierst
[Musik]
das wird schön aber mein innerer morgen
gesagt mir dreht die beiden hälften so
dass die schrift passt schon jetzt ganz
durch dann sind beide seiten schön
[Musik]
tja und dann gucke ich mal jetzt gleich
den kuchen probiert
ich glaube ich überrascht
ja
ich hole nicht
sagen ich will vielleicht dazu sonst ist
er traurig jetzt kann probiert werden
[Musik]
wer könnte diesen käsekuchen er probiert
als die zauberhafte wunderbare
einzigartige anna ich doch gerade wer
mit
[Applaus]
screen und
mit pürierten timpen obendrauf das ist
ein gaumenschmaus
ich schneide ihn jetzt
[Musik]
ich bin
gespannt
ob erteilen kalorienbedarf heute oder
morgen
war richtig sauer werden sollte meint
wohnen so langsam mal anmerken dass wir
vielleicht ein fitnessstudio
beitrags zahlen könnte weil
die wird jetzt kein kuchen mal probieren
oder doch aber ich musste dann
trainieren habe mir da reif ist
kostenlos
ja okay dass ich gut aus außerdem kenne
ich noch jemand der auch gut aussieht
und der richtig fit ist
und der blaue haare
das hat ja vielleicht schon mal gesehen
dass wir uns so gegenüber sitzen
haben
ja oder
ja
kuchen schweizer käse
ich mich mich wunderts war weil er oben
so roten wären doch gott sei na ja und
dass thomas
u16 unserem team
noch einen tick bekommen
du trainierst schon auf das sehe ich
immer
zwei drei mal die woche
er schafft das was ich nicht schaffe
liege dem züge kannst du das muss mal
als ein vergnügen
ich bin ich auch nicht will die frau
muss man keine lee geschützt und kann
ich dem zu schaffen außer frauen legen
statistik steht
[Musik]
finde ich auch gut wie viele winzige
chance das kommt halt darauf an aber
sonst auch ein vaeth dranhängt milse so
am stück
so 15 20
guck mal ein lautes finde ich super
schöner hätte ich die ganzen kaffee dazu
ganz genau
also wir sind hier ja alles eine familie
wir essen immer von einem teller bleibt
in der familie
das sieht richtig gut aus
der thomas ist
sofort wieder käsekuchen
[Musik]
was ist seinen lieblingskuchen
ich hab die hessen mit dem gerasterten
muster sind sie ja genau das ist aber
gut erkannt
und
so unterbinden aber ich finde so man hat
sagte sind die besten
ich muss sagen was was mich überrascht
der lotus dies macht also der punkt
richtig gut drauf und ja
ich hätte tatsächlich kurz gedacht dass
die himbeeren so ein bisschen dem lotus
die show stehlen aber nein ergänzte ich
sie kommen
aber so hardcore fans können hoffentlich
kriegen ihre platzierung ein punkt wo du
es noch mal so ein
land machen
ok jetzt eskaliert das rezept findet ihr
in meiner app in der sallys welt app da
könnt ihr nochmal alles nachlesen das
rezept unter den favoriten speichern und
so weiter probiert also gerne mal aus
und wir freuen uns aufs nächste mal also
ich zu
das warten übrigens noch alle auf das
musical mit dem fertigen song ja wir
müssen das noch dichten ja wir müssen es
noch kategorisch auch drauf unbedingt
spitze dann eine rolle wenn
ihr schneemann ist schon was anderes im
hintergrund
tönte da
aus zwischen vereist war als der prinz
[Musik]